[Music]
Dr. uh Raymond Katrrol uh who had just
retired gave another Adventist forum.
This was in San
Diego and he was on the committee that
wrote the Bible SDA Bible commentary.
And because he was the denomination's
best Hebrew scholar, their number one
Hebrew scholar, he was assigned to write
on Daniel. Well, he got to Daniel 8:14
and he could not get Adventist
interpretation out of Daniel 8:14. So,
he went to uh Elder Low who was in
charge of the committee and then the two
of them went to RR Figure who was the
general conference president at the
time. And they said, "Look, we can't get
Adventist theology out of Daniel 8." And
that's the pillar of the Adventist
church. Well, Furer said, "You get the
best minds of
Adventism and you form a super super
secret committee and you work on this
problem until it's
solved." So they did. They got the best
minds of Adventism and they're the men
are listed in my book, Cultic Doctrine.
and uh they worked on it for 5 years and
realized they could
not biblically support it. So they
didn't know what to do. If if we say
it's not biblical, then that blows the
church up. And if we say it is, we're
lying. So they finally disbanded and
left no minutes as if they'd never met.
And they were instructed to tell the
pastors to continue to teach the
investigative judgment based on
traditional assumptions.
Well, so that was the second thing. I
knew it was wrong. I knew they knew it
was wrong and it tried to cover it up.
Then, uh, the next thing that happened
was I in the mail one day, I got a set
of six either five or six long cassette
tapes from Dr. Zayn Kim. He was a
medical doctor, a friend of mine. And I
did not ask for them. And what happened
was that Doc uh Walter Ray, who was a
pastor I'd known in Southern California,
and I think you may have his book there.
Well, yeah, I'm looking for it right
now. Here it is. Uh yeah, Walter Ray,
it's a book, White Line. By the way, we
have this on our website. Uh anyway, he
uh he was really strong believer in
Ellen White and he wrote a lot of books
summarizing some of the quotes from
Ellen White. I'll set this down.
Anyway, and he was reading some old
books on the life of Christ and suddenly
he realized, man, that sure sounds like
Ellen White.
And that so he would went and said, "Oh,
that's that's almost like Ellen White
says." So he that piqued his interest.
He got a copy of the all the books that
Ellen White had in her library and tried
to find them. And lo and behold, he
found that Ellen White plagiarized huge
amounts of material. And that's what
this book is all about. He documents
everything in this book called the the
white lie from the research you're
referring to right now. Exactly.
Exactly. Now, the way they she
plagiarized and she had some secretaries
that helped her, they would change a
word here or change a word there, put in
a synonym or something else that would
sound the same or but but but change it
so it wouldn't be quite as evident. So,
it was it was u deceptive plagiarism, if
you will. Anyway, he found that she had
plagiarized huge amounts in her books,
even in her testimonies to individual
people. Uh sometimes even her dreams
that she had were quotes from some books
and uh even in places where she said uh
said the angel and she would quote she
had an angel that supposedly spoke to
her. She claimed to have 2,000 visions
and so on. And often she says um uh I
was shown you know like the angel of God
told her and then she'd quote something
and lo and behold even those I was shown
statements often were from some other
author. So basically the angels that uh
Ellen White was talking to were really
these other authors that had written
books that were in her library.
Yeah, you might say that. Now she's
written a lot of good things too and she
she quotes from some good authors at
times. Okay, so those are three things.
I knew I couldn't trust Ellen White
anymore. I knew the Adventist church,
their investigative judgment was wrong.
And I knew they knew it was wrong. So
about this
time, Adventism, this all this stuff
started leak out in the Adventist church
and there was a tremendous underground.
People were discussing it and I was
pastor of the Watsonville church and
people were asking me about my research
and so on and Dr. uh Raymond Katrol's
tape I uh were out okay and I had some
very professional PhD type uh and MD uh
elders on my church board so I felt free
to give it to them and say look let's
consider this because I had always
thought that truth was the hallmark of
Adventism and I've always sought for
truth I mean I always want to be a truth
seeker
well the quote hit the fan about that
time. I got a call from the conference
president. He wanted to talk to me and
he said, "I understand you shared all
this." Anyway, to make a long story
short,
uh I told him why I c I could not preach
the investigative judgment. And he says,
"Well, you got to do it." And I says, "I
can't unless you can show me how to do
it." Well, he had me meet with two
people. Harold West, who was a
ministerial secretary, like the pastor
over the pastors, and uh Mr. Dr. Zamora
who pastored a large Adventist church in
the San Jose area. He had been at the
Glacier View trial and he had read that
thousandpage manuscript too. Mhm. So we
met for four hours. It was recorded.
They never gave me a copy and I know
it'll never be released because both of
them admitted in private that Daniel 8
probably referred to Antioch's epiphies.
we should not use Ellen White for
doctrine and there was no problem with
you
know two weeks later about a camp
meeting they were up in front quoting
Ellen White pro promoting the same
Adventist and I began to lose faith
in the uh the
personnel of Adventism. One day Harold
West knew I was struggling. He took me
aside and it was it was a camp meeting.
He took me for a walk. He said Dave
let's go for a walk. I want to talk to
you. So, we wanted to go for a walk
where nobody could hear us. And he said,
"Dale, we both know the doctrine's
wrong. It's not our fault. We can't do
anything about it. Look at the church as
your employer and do what you can with a
clear conscience and don't make any
waves and you'll be fine. It's good
retirement here."
And I said, "Herold, God called me to
teach the truth of the gospel. Maybe I'm
in the wrong denomination."
Well, the day came when we resigned. We
had to uh at the time we had just built
a new house and those that was in the
80s. Our first loan was 12%, our second
was 18.
My wife was employed at the church. Uh
she was a evangelistic Bible worker like
my grandmother. We thought we'd probably
lose our house. We didn't. The Lord has
provided. And
uh when I left, I had determined we
would never speak against Adventism. I
didn't want to be one of these, you
know, people, sour grapes, people. But
then over the years, uh, I started a
church, mostly former Adventists. A lot
of the people who a lot of members of
the Watsonville church came with me when
I left and, uh, we started a church.
It's in my book, uh, Truth Led Me Out.
But, right. In fact, anyway, you kept
the name Adventist in the name of that
church. What was the name of that
church? Well, at first it was, uh, the
Biblical Adventist Church. Uhhuh. And
then we got all kinds of flack from
that. By the way, who was giving you the
flack? Well, um, the church was
Adventist Church. The Seventh Day
Adventists were giving you a hard time
about using that name. Absolutely.
Because they didn't consider you part of
them. No anymore. In fact, some of our
friends at Monterey Bay Academy, we have
still friends out there. Okay. We're
coming to our church.
And they got a letter from the
conference president said, "If you
continue that, you're going to be lose
your job." So they they didn't want
anybody to come to our church.
Threatening them with their employment.
So we changed the name to Biblical
Fellowship Church. Now two years after I
left, I was I just, by the way, this is
a good insight. I decided I'd put the
writings of Ellen White. I picked out
all of her books and she's written a
stack of books about that high. Put them
in the garage and I said, I will not
look at these for six
months. Wow. If you like our YouTube
channel, please subscribe by clicking on
the subscribe button and then by also
clicking the bell above to get an
automatic update whenever we produce
another YouTube video for our C answers
TV channel. Please share our videos with
your friends and relatives. May God
bless you. Only one life will soon be
passed. Only what is done for Christ
will last.
[Music]